My name is V., from V. Wings, and today we're together for the equipment topic.
The topic — it comes up in theory, or rather in theory courses,
with a lot of technical terms and details divided in two parts.
We've got two midday segments here, and at any point feel free to jump in
with questions during the session.
That way the learning works simply.
What we're all going to look at today is what's actually out there in terms of flight equipment,
to give you some background on what different paragliders exist,
what you can do with them — from acro paragliders all the way down to the school wing.
We'll look at how such a paraglider is built, the material side. We'll look
at the reserve parachute, and we'll look at the materials used, specifically, in detail,
including the paraglider lines, because it's really important to know how the whole thing is going to behave.
When we look at the paraglider categories, on the one hand we have the school wing.
That's the picture all the way on the left.
The white-red one — you can already see, that's a simple wing.
It's not crazily high-aspect-ratio, but really relatively compact.
And the big difference between the school wing and the competition wing, if you look at how it's built,
is ultimately that a school wing is built to be safe.
Safety is the absolute priority — performance isn't as important.
Sub-categorised, the competition wing is the exact opposite —
performance is what matters, and safety takes a bit of a back seat.
But it's tiered, because the wing demands a lot from the pilot — that they can already handle a lot.
And of course there are many more sub-categories.
For example, on the right, the red one — that's a real specialist model,
which are built very robustly.
Also weight plays a role — that's an acro wing,
you saw a white one there, and it's made so you can't fly with it normally,
the most extreme loads, the most extreme stresses on the wing,
but the material holds, because it's built that way — built really strong.
And then we have categories of speed gliding,
where you go with skis and very small wings, which you fly.
Here too, it's a form of paragliding flying.
All these things are in other categories, which we won't go into in detail now.
The whole of paragliding is also rated,
the different classifications.
The A, B, C and D.
And with the A-wing we're talking about the school wing.
That means, as it says there, the passive safety is very high.
Ultimately the idea is that if a disturbance happens on the school wing
and the pilot just lets go,
the wing comes back to straight flight on its own.
That's the goal of the school-wing design.
The designer who builds the wing tries, as firmly as possible,
to prevent issues.
And to stay in a range where you can say
the wing behaves very, very safely.
The performance.
The glide ratio is always against altitude lost.
That means, for example, from 1,000 metres,
if you launch in calm air and just,
from the wing,
then with a school wing we can go 8 km.
With a competition wing we're now at 12 km.
That's already 8 km.
Which is already very, very good.
When we compare it — just a few years ago,
we were at 7.5 km, and now we're at 8 km,
or even already over.
Next we move on to the B,
the intermediate,
where most pilots,
what I fly, that is,
is,
what comes after the school wing,
when you've already done a few flights,
say after about 100 flights on a school wing,
you move on to a B-wing,
which still has pretty good passive safety,
but then there's also the performance.
And the pilot already has to know a bit
what they're doing,
to react quickly and respectively recover from a disturbance.
On the C-wing, even more so.
On the D-wing, when you're heading into competition wing territory,
that's definitely the case,
what the wing demands of the pilot.
That it's, uh,
when something happens,
if you don't catch it in time,
(unclear)
The real EN norm,
which we encounter,
is valid worldwide.
In Austria and Germany
there's also the LTF,
which is all the DHV-certified wings.
It's absolutely important detail-wise,
but the German pilots,
the pilots in Germany, only fly with LTF-tested wings.
Worldwide, the EN-certified wings apply.
What's done
is that, on one hand, the wing
is tested with a shock load,
attached to a long line, the vehicle drives off, and the line has a designed breaking point
in it, so the riser and so on with the wing don't take any damage,
so that nothing gets damaged. If the tests are successful, the wing is normally rigged up.
The car drives off continuously, accelerating more and more, so that the wing,
where the risers are loaded to 8G. 8G is the absolute minimum today,
for the certification, and rather above that — usually it's around 12 or even 60G,
if you take an acro wing, for example — we're certainly more in the 60G range.
And then a report gets written that it didn't break, that all
the construction parts and so on are intact. And a seam pull test is done, and all that is
documented. What's also done is testing the line strength,
checking that they're as the manufacturer specified, and the bending tests
follow, where the manufacturer must compartmentalise in advance and prove
that the lines they've built in, the load on the seams, and also
the correct seam connections, where the load is. All of this is tested, tested,
recorded, and then you move on to the flight test.
The flight test first looks very generally at the brake travel — on a competition wing
the brake travel is certainly shorter, maybe 0 to 30 centimetres, and on a
school wing it's typically in the range of 0 to 50 or 60 centimetres — relatively long.
That's looked at. And then
the whole thing is a bit tricky, because there's no measuring method for it.
That means it's ultimately in the eye of the beholder, an expert who does it, and
the test pilot, whose judgement decides whether it's now an A or a B. The
whole thing is that each test has to be flown five times, and if it once
falls into the category you want, that counts. That means it
can fail four times and pass once as an A, and then it's classified as A for that manoeuvre. That's something
that gets criticised, especially by the flight school, because actually for the brake-stall behaviour, if it
would need to be a majority — that, for example, 3 times out of 5 in the brake stall it goes into a stall
and 2 times it doesn't — that would be more meaningful. But even so
importantly, the wing tendencies are documented for us, so you get advice at the flight school
already, beyond just the brake-stall category.
and they actually prevent the tear from running further if there's already a hole.
It's like a small barrier.
And the barrier is woven in thicker so that it doesn't propagate,
but I also have very thin fabrics.
Which have low weight and are still very stable,
above all.
What's there?
It's been brought up.
The lightweight construction segment, where the manufacturer builds a wing,
perhaps designed for hike-and-fly,
where you want it light and with small pack volume.
There you go down to as low as 17 grams per square metre.
And that number, I'm sure,
will go even further down in the future,
because the techniques keep advancing and progress is made,
and of course a key concern
is to have fabrics that are equally stable
but even lighter than the rest.
What other materials do we have built in?
We have the wing itself.
We've now learned that it's ultimately nylon.
I also have here, in the back-recovery area, where they've
now started to build in a bit of PET-bottle material
into the paraglider, to put it loosely.
So we're also dealing with a plastic mix
in the paraglider segment.
Also in the strap segment, that's the thin technora material.
From the line side we'll get to that in a moment,
specifically.
We have the reserve parachute itself,
where everything is also nylon.
In the reserve parachute, it's all the same.
It's just woven much, much, much more loosely.
It's even thinner.
Of course, the loading on the reserve parachute is different.
First of all.
For the reserve parachute fabrics.
It's not so important that it's fully dimensionally stable.
Because precisely when it opens with a shock,
the important thing is that the whole thing,
with the lines, but also through it.
The pressure there,
if the fabric isn't fully stable,
we can also get to that in a moment.
What we also have are carabiners.
We have steel and aluminium on the market.
Opinions are divided,
the long discussion of which to choose,
which is really better now.
Aluminium has a slight disadvantage,
with mechanical loading — that is,
if we strike a stone,
an aluminium one will pick up a dent more quickly
than a steel carabiner.
Otherwise they last very, very long and well.
And in general use,
you'd swap them out every five years.
The aluminium carabiner,
in tests,
even very slightly,
performed better,
when a test was done
where you do a few mini-minute cycles
of opening and closing,
and that 2,000 times,
ultimately the strength
of aluminium was better.
We're also talking about strength,
which can't be undershot
in normal use.
Right.
The paraglider has lots of lines.
That's the thing,
where it's also crucial.
Because with these lines
you can do a lot,
by mixing materials.
And we try
to design the best,
so every wing flies as long as possible
the way it was newly built.
Because the wear creates a difference,
certain lines
shrink,
stretch,
and that's why it's important
to have the right mix there.
We distinguish, however,
on line material
between,
the sheath.
It's not just about a thin coating.
It's also about a thin coating.
Such lines,
an entirely new range
over the list,
where you now opt for that,
in practice.
A bit different,
than with (unclear).
The flux,
into the line,
(unclear),
the types,
here,
there.
(unclear),
where you handle it.
You can,
to test,
drag, and various materials get built up there.
First of all,
the brand name of this line,
the white line that we have here,
is already a different polyester line, a synthetic.
And it has a good colour.
The polyester line is yet another synthetic.
And it has a big advantage,
that it has a very good weight-to-strength ratio.
It's light and has very, very high durability,
and it's also very good,
and it's very good for everyday work.
It's not quite as sensitive,
if you don't have super precise notes,
and above all, under low loads,
they tend to shrink a bit.
That means,
when the paraglider is naturally flying,
it has roughly 80% of the total load on the A and B riser groups,
and at the back, on the C or D riser groups, the remaining 20% is.
That naturally means,
if you build the lines into the C and D area,
which get less loaded,
and the (unclear)
the (unclear).
Then we have the wing shrinking there.
The others, by brand,
you have to look carefully where you build them in.
Because, naturally, when there's a part on the wing
where, as you say, it now gets loaded,
then it's important that they're insensitive there
to kinking or to length stability.
That's why it's always a mix between the aramid lines
and the Dyneema lines,
you say with the upper area,
probably more the Dyneema inside,
the lower aramid lines,
to simply get the best mix possible,
very good.